bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction sur
TV fil 78 et dans l'actualité yvelinoise
en ce jeudi 2 avril avec une assemblée
entièrement acquise à la droite et au
centre Pierre Bédier récupère son poste
de président du conseil départemental
des ivelines l'élection se tenait ce
matin les réactions à suivre un accueil
de jours départemental pour les femmes
victimes de violence inaugurée à Montini
le Bretonneux son fonctionnement
expliqué tout à l'heure par sa
directrice notamment Hélène Colombier
invitée de cette édition et puis cloche
ou lapin pour vu que ce soit en chocolat
pasx c'est ce weekend détour par
l'atelier de Franck dobau Sam Montini le
Bretonneux ou se prépare quelques
douceurs pour les enfants et pour les
adultes
également dans le cadre de la Semaine de
l'Industrie l'aéroport de toussul noble
a organisé une journée spéciale sur les
métiers de l'aéronautique au total plus
de 4 400 jeunes étaient présents pour ce
rendez-vous cette journée s'inscrivait
également dans un projet de
développement d'un pôle aéronautique
autour de l'aéroport le préfet des
iblines était au micro de Michel elmido
et de Mélanie poet donc on dit aux
jeunes venez venez rencontrer les
médecines aéronautique venez et
peut-être que ça vous y trouverait votre
bonheur et que peut-être vous ferez une
carrière d'onautique et puis le deuxième
sujet qui pour nous très important ici à
toussu aujourd'hui nous avons décidé
avec les élus la chambre de commces des
entreprises de voir comment on pouvait
transformer tout dans l'aéroport dans
l'aérodrome du 21e siècle un aérodrome
exemplaire au cœur de Paris saclé en
maillant ce qui est l'automobile
intelligente et l'automobile électrique
avec l'avion intelligent l'avion
électrique tout ça ici à tout su et dans
le cadre de cette édition je reçois
aujourd'hui Hélène Colombier directrice
de l'établissement public l'équinoxe à
Montin le Bretonneux bonsoir et
également Olivia de Bour bonsoir vous
êtes cadre socio éducat dans ce centre
l'équinoxe structure d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale qui dorénavant
dispose aussi d'un accueil de jour
départemental pour les femmes victimes
de violence l'étincelle c'est son nom
qui a d'ailleurs été inauguré ce jeudi
midi le reportage et on en parle juste
après vous pouvez couper he parce que
sinon
oui voilà un nouvel accueil de jour
départemental pour les femmes victimes
de violence ouvre ses portes à Montin le
Bretonneux l'étincelle c'est son nom a
été inauguré ce midi en présence
notamment du préfet
et de Michel logier ce lieu va devenir
quand même un lieu de écoute un lieu de
conseil pour aider ces personnes qui
sont face à ces problèmes c'est la
poursuite déjà du travail entrepris avec
donc le CHRS l'équinoxe qui remplit déjà
largement sa mission puisque j'allais
dire hélas c'est un vrai succès et même
on a du mal à faire face à toutes les
demandes implanté dans les locaux du
centre d'hébergement de réinsertion
sociale l'Équinox l'étincelle proposera
aux victimes des ateliers thématiques
des groupes de parole des permanences
juridiqu ou encore des actions de
soutien individuelles et collectifs un
accueil qui s'inscrit dans le cadre du
4e plan interministériel de prévention
et de lutte contre les violences faites
aux femmes et qui met à contribution les
acteurs du territoire on n'est pas
différent des autres départements et
c'est malheureusement un un phénomène
qui est extrêmement répandu la
révélation de ces faits est de plus en
plus forte c'està dire que les femmes
restent elles sont de moins en moins
paniqué à l'idée même de
venir dire leur douleurs dire les Cices
qu'elles subissent l'étincelle dispose
également d'un service de mise en
sécurité quelques logements prêts à
accueillir les victimes sont déjà
implanté sur hencour Versailles et
bientôt voisin le
Bretonneux nous continuons à évoquer
cette structure avec nos invités on a
entendu dans ce reportage que cet
accueil s'inscrivait dans le cadre du 4e
plan interministériel de prévention de
lutte contre les violences qui sont
faites aux femmes c'est un rôle capital
pour le département c'est de là que tout
sera coordonné pour le département des
yvelin nous l'espérons nous l'espérons
effectivement la création de cet accueil
de jour est un événement puisque le les
Yvelines étaitent le dernier département
francilien à ne pas en disposer voilà
chose faite nous espérons ouvrir la
structure et accueillir très
prochainement les victimes le choix de
l'implantation au sein de de l'équinoxe
tout de même pourquoi cette implantation
sur ce lieu alors euh surtout en raison
de l'accessibilité du réseau et de la de
la position centrale géographique de 50
eneline par rapport au département qui
permet un accès extrêmement facile par
les voies de transport mais avoir un
centre sur 50 ans nieline ça va
permettre de concerner l'ensemble des
femmes qui sont victimes de violence
dans tout le département absolument
absolument si l'on a implanté à Montini
pour autant l'ensemble des femmes auront
vocation à venir de l'ensemble du
département mais ce sera peut-être un
peu plus difficile d'aller chercher
celles qui sont plus loin est-ce qu'il y
aura des relais qui seront opérés à
travers le département al nous espérons
bien évidemment nous appuyer déjà sur
les partenaires qui sont déjà en place
sur les territoires et qui vont nous les
orienter euh que ce soit les
professionnels de santé les services de
police de gendarmerie tous les
intervenants qui travaillent déjà et qui
sont déjà au contact de ces femmes
victimes de violence par rapport à
l'implantation toujours au sein de de
l'équinoxe c'est pour une
complémentarité aussi des missions pour
faciliter le travail entre l'étincell
donc cette nouvelle structure et
l'équinoxe alors c'est une deuxème
activité H qui vient en parallèle qui
est différente dans sa finalité
effectivement qui vient enrichir
l'activité de l'établissement public
mais qui s'adresse à un public différent
spécifique et qui a une mission
différente al lorsque vous dites c'est
en parallèle ça veut dire qu'il y aura
des nouvelles personnes qui vont y
travailler c'est pas du travail
supplémentaire pour celles qui sont déjà
tout fait tout à fait c'est une nouvelle
activité qui vient s'ajouter aux
missions déjà exercé par le CHRS alors
comment ça va se passer concrètement
pour ces femmes qui sont victimes de
violence qui viennent vous voir à qui
elles doivent s'adresser puis ensuite
comment elles sont prises en charge sur
place alors l'idée effectivement de
pouvoir proposer aux personnes déjà un
lieu d'accueil hein où elle puisse au
moins retrouver un peu de sérénité dans
un premier temps et dans un second temps
effectivement le maillage partenarial
réalisé au sein du du département devra
faire en sorte en tout cas c'est c'est
le le but et l'objectif de pouvoir
remettre la personne au centre de son
parcours et effectivement pouvoir
orienter vers les différents
spécialistesin du département ou du
secteur concerné en fonction
effectivement d'une personne qui vient
ou de la casquie ou du nord du
département ou du du sud du département
et et pour l'accueil l'adresse va
s'afficher bien sûr à l'antenne si
jamais vous souhaitez rentrer en contact
avec l'étincelle c'est au sein de
l'équinoxe c'est à montinil Bretonneux
sur l'avenue Nicolas Abou concrètement
une femme vient vous voir et ensuite
elle est tout de suite prise en charge
il y a une structure de protection aussi
qui se qui se met en place comment ça se
passe tout d'abord une évaluation une
évaluation de la situation en fonction
effectivement on va dire du du mode
d'entrée dans la structure soit la
personne bien a eu connaissance et donc
est venue par elle-même donc là une
première évaluation qui qui sera faite
pour pouvoir effectivement euh euh
orienter correctement la personne en
fonction de ses besoins euh ou deuxème
possibilité orientation en direct par un
partenaire euh où là effectivement on va
pas faire une évaluation si elle a déjà
été faite par un partenaire mais on va
plutôt assurer une complémentarité et ça
se fait dans l'anonymat aussi des
victimes cette protection et il y a une
la confidentialité et c'est gratuit
c'est libre d'accès sans rendez-vous et
c'est avec les enfants également parce
que cette question là se pose aussi pour
les femmes qui peuvent vouloir faire les
démarches de ne pas laisser leurs
enfants absolument pour faciliter
justement la venue de ces femmes dans la
structure nous avons prévu un espace
d'accueil pour les enfants donc les
femmes pourront venir
librement séparément et les enfants
seront accueillis à part dans un are
lieu de la structure quelle est la la
durée du du suivi là ça se met en place
mais combien de temps les personnes
peuvent rester aussi longtemps que c'est
nécessaire est-ce qu'il y a une limite
elles pourront revenir chaque jour euh
puisque la structure sera ouverte sans
interruption de 9h30 à 16h30
elles pourront venir plusieurs fois si
elle le souhaite en fonction bah des
nécessités donc il y aura pas de durée
maximum aujourd'hui pour ces violences
qui sont faites aux femmes est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que la parole se
libère aussi avec la création de ces
structures par exemple j'ai pas donné
quelques chiffres que je peux tout même
rappeler une femme décède tous les 2
jours et demi en France 148 femmes par
an dont 25 en Île-deFrance et dans les
ivelines et seulement 20 % de celles qui
subissent des violences se déplacent à
la police ou à la gendarmerie mais
aujourd'hui malgré tout la parole se
libère euh il semblerait que l'effet
constaté par les services de police et
gendarmerie tendent dans ce sens puisque
Monsieur le Préfet disait ce matin que
il constatait effectivement une
augmentation de ces de ces chiffres donc
on peut supposer effectivement que un
plus grand nombre de personnes viennent
faire des démarches pour déposer plainte
et pour faciliter tout cela est-ce qu'il
y a des axes de développement qui sont
prévus la structure vient d'ouvrir
aujourd'hui à Montini mais est-ce qu'il
est prévu de de s'élargir un peu plus
sur l'ensemble du département ou d'avoir
d'autres types de d'accueil de ce jour
alors là on est sur un accue
départemental qui a vocation à
centraliser et à à animer le réseau en
quelque sorte des partenaires déjà
existants euh si l'on est implanté sur
motini il ne faut pas oublier pour
autant que nous avons un service de mise
en sécurité qui lui est une sorte un
service annexe qui va consister en des
logements disséminés sur l'ensemble du
territoire h donc donc en fait les
personnes pourront bénéficier des
services et des prestations de
l'étincelle depuis les territoires un
maillage sur l'ensemble du département
déjà qui est opérationnel une dernière
question un petit mot ce rubon blanc que
vous portez bah c'est le signe de la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes voilà aujourd'hui on mettra aussi
vous auriez dû m' ramener he que je
puisse mettre également tout à fait pour
finir le journal merci à toutes les deux
d'être venu nous parler de cette
nouvelle structure le centre l'étincelle
située donc à Montini le bretonné au
cœur de l'Équinox avenue Nicolas Abou on
continue ce journal on va parler
politique à présent les 42 nouveaux
conseillers départementaux étaient
réunis ce jeudi matin pour lire le
président de l'assemblée départementale
et sans surprise un seul candidat Pierre
Bédier il a été élu avec 38 voix quatre
bulletins étaient blancs dans son
discours il a appelé à la mobilisation
de l'ensemble des élus dans un esprit
d'humilité malgré tout et de combat
Catherine zulato et William l a obtenu
voix il y a 4 blanc monsieur ber
félicitations
sans surprise un seul candidat pour la
présidence du nouveau conseil
départemental un conseil passé
entièrement à droite et un seul élu
Pierre Bédier il retrouve ainsi son
fauteuil par 38 voix et qure bulletins
blancs toutefois l'ordre du jour par la
fixation toute élection j'ai voté blanc
alors voyez donc qu'il y en a que
trois ça n'a aucune importance aucune
importance pas pour tout le monde la
doyenne de l'assemblée Christine Boutin
y voit la marque d'une liberté
indispensable au sein d'une assemblée
unicolore dans une assemblée
unicolore comme la nôtre il est
indispensable que nous ayons la liberté
la liberté de de voter en conscience
parce que sinon ça risque donner une
image très autoritaire très dictatorial
de notre assemblée vous savez les hommes
et les femmes politiques ont très
souvent tendance à se mettre des boulets
aux pied alors qu'on leur demande d'être
libre là et bien chacun a voté en toute
liberté et le président est très bien
élu très bien élu et bien entouré Pierre
Bédier disposera de 12 vice-présidents
et de 29 membres dans la commission
permanente une nouvelle façon aussi de
travailler dans une assemblée renouvelée
à 60 % et qui marque l'entrée de
nombreux élus de notre secteur Joséphine
colpasberger devient 4e vice-présidente
le président euh choisit effectivement
moi c'est des demandes c'est une demande
que j'avais euh faite d'être dans la
culture j'avais pas demander
particulièrement je dirais une
vice-présidence je crois que le fait que
nous arrivions euh euh au niveau des des
femmes dans cette parité fait aussi je
suis obligé de le dire nous donne ces
opportunités là donc je je suis très
très fière très heureuse beaucoup
d'émotion beaucoup de fierté beaucoup
d'inconnu aussi de savoir ce qu'on va y
faire non non on est très heureux moi je
suis très très content d'être là autres
élus Michel logier et Jean-Michel
Fourgous maire de leur commune et pour
l'un président de la casquie et pour
l'autre vice-président de
l'agglomération eux ne parlent pas de
cumule des mandats mais de
complémentarité des fonctions fait pas
beaucoup il suffit d'être déjà bien
organisé 1 de je n'ai plus aucune
activité professionnelle en dehors de
mes activités politiques et 3 je ne
traite que des sujets qui sont très
complémentaires puisque quand je parle
des sujets d'une ville et bien c'est
tout de suite avec l'intercommunalité
aussi avec Laé d'agglomération et bien
souvent tous les dossiers la plupart des
dossiers que nous passons ont une
incidence aussi avec le Conseil
départemental donc je gère exactement
les mêmes dossiers et la coordination
avec laakquie donc la une grosse Inter
du département plus la région si demain
effectivement on peut travailler avec la
région beaucoup mieux en harmonie sur
des avec une vraie culture économique on
oublie un peu la politique politicienne
et puis qu'on fasse vraiment des grands
projets d'intérêts généraux unumule des
fonctions qui permet aussi à certains de
se positionner la mre de plaisir a
annoncé qu'elle renoncerait à certaines
indemnités j'ai entendu pendant la
campagne oh là là le cumul des mandats
le cumulle des mandats je sa très bien
que on pense moins à à l'énergie que je
dois mettre et au temps que je dois
mettre que aux rémunérations y a des
indemnité que je vais refuser que je
vais redistribuer autrement ou laisser
dans le pot commun je dirais de la
strate de la structure ou bien de
redistribuer à des élus qui sont autour
de moi c'est une évidence je lui faire
après cette première séance les élus ont
siégé en commission ils auront peu de
temps pour prendre leur marque la
prochaine séance est le 12 avril pour le
débat d'orientation budgétaire le cap a
d'ors et déjà été fixé par le nouveau
président la
solidarité parce que c'est notre mission
première mais la Solidarité sociale doit
être conjuguée avec la solidarité
territorial et aussi le combat à mené
dans la constitution du Grand Paris un
danger selon lui pour la grande couronne
parisienne on est au combat c'est un
combat
pacifique mais c'est la nécessité
vraiment de de de peser dans tous les
débats tout de suite et cette assemblée
se mobilise pour cela un autre moment
attend la nouvelle Assemblée ce sera le
vote du budget le 17
avril et puis politique toujours avec la
création du club initiative 78 un club
créé par le vice président du MoDem dans
le département et qui entend partager
expérience analyser les décisions prises
et les résultats ce soir au Café de
l'industrie c'est à Saint-Germain en
lait le thème retenu les TPE PME les TPI
PMI et puis également le RSI 50
personnes attendu élu membres de la
société civile et puis bien sûr les
adhérents du MoDem au chapitre sport à
présent la sélection française de
l'armée de l'air de rugby qui a
rencontré les Anglais de la Royal Air
Force la rencontre était programmée ce
mercredi au stade porsche-fontaine à
Versailles un reportage de Michel et dem
d'EUR sur des images de Patrick Jacques
de
dixmud un franceangleterre un peu
particulier ce mercredi la sélection
française de l'armée de l'air qui jou en
noir recevait les Britanniques de la
Royal Air Force au stade Porchefontaine
de versaill une véritable tradition dans
l'armée de l'air c'est un match qui
avait repris en 1945 àu de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et nous avons depuis 3
ou 4 ans essayé de remettre ça au goût
du jour afin que nos relations avec nos
amis britanniques soient amélioré et que
on améliore par la même notre niveau de
rugby au total ils étent plus d'une
centaine de spectateurs à garnir les
travaers du stade de porschefontaine
certains étaient plus célèbres que
d'autres ce sont de équipe nationale
donc forcément on a tous envie de de
voir un crunch même si c'est un crunch
Armée de l'Air on a toujours toujours
envie de voir une confrontation France
Angleterre et et encore je le répète le
cadre est très sympa il y a du monde et
ça vaut le coup parce que les joueurs ne
trichent pas sur le terrain et le niveau
est sympa ce match n'avait d'amical que
le nom les contacts étaient et la
tension était palpable des deux côtés
après avoir tenu en échec les anglais
pendant plus de 70 minutes le 15
français a craqué à 2 minutes de la fin
du match avec deux essais concédés coup
sur coup score final 20
à6 c'était un match serré et très
tactique c'était très dur de gagner ce
match nous n'avons réussi à scorer qu'à
5 minutes de la fin c'était vraiment
très serré on manqué concrétiser dans le
moment fort et et après eux par contre
tous leur moment fort que soit en
première mi-temps ou en 2uxème ils ont
marqué il vient deux fois en deuxième
mi-temps il marque deux essais et pareil
en première mi-temps il score au pied
donc voilà c'est la du sport et du rugby
surtout c'est vraiment super et bon il y
a eu un peu d'engagement cétait bien
aussi la sélection française de l'armée
de l'air et les Britanniques de la Royal
Air Force devrait se retrouver en
octobre en Angleterre pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby
militaire les fêtes de pâqu qui
approchent à grand pas c'est la dernière
ligne droite pour tous les
professionnels du chocolat Mélanie poet
plus que quelques jours à tenir avant de
pouvoir céder à la gourmandise au
laboratoire de boss on apporte les
dernières touches aux commandes et pour
les fêtes de pâqu les classiques ont
toujours la côte c'est quand même
traditionnel c'est d'abord les œufs les
cloches les poissons après les petits
montage mais c'est surtout les
œufs chocolat noir chocolat au lait
praliné pour les fêtes de pâqu Franck
debos et ses employés produit jusqu'à
une tonne 400 de chocolat pour
satisfaire les gourmands c'est 18 18 à
20 % de
des chiffres d'affaires en chocolat
d'cord c'est avant après ça dépend des
périodes que pas ça tombe mal ça tombe
pendant les vacances B tout de suite on
travaille beaucoup moins bien que si
c'est comme cette année où tout le monde
est là les cloches vont être bientôt
finalisées de quoi pouvoir nous livrer à
temps le journal revient demain vendredi
aux mêmes horaires nous reviendrons sur
l'actualité de la semaine écoulée
également sur l'actualité du jour ce
soir sur TV fil nouveau numéro de filco
le magazine économique de la rédaction
prépar présenté par Flor parfit
excellente
soirée